one to three things that you'd be like
if you keep really focusing on this ham
I think you'll be all right what what
are those things yeah I mean ultimately
it's it's making sure that you are going
at your Market properly and you need to
be making sure that you're not leaving
any stone unturned even if it's a cold
lead one day you know that that's going
to come back around in Full Circle and
it might deliver you a job in the future
so from a client called perspective the
second thing would be discover and
create a USP because there is a lot of
people in the market everyone's coming
with the same sale I'm a specialist I've
got a great database I can you know I've
got the people like why is a client
going to use you over someone else right
it can be as simple as just asking a
client you know I get it you probably
get a load of recruits calling you how
can I make a difference and just put it
to them let them tell you so trying to
stand out obviously in a competitive
market making sure that your Sal's a
little bit different and just being an
absolute Workhorse and not leaving any
stone unturned is is is definitely my
advice I give to anyone starting out